- What's up Believe Nation.
Today I'm going to share with you
my Favorite Top 10 Rules for Success,
April 2017 edition.
And as always guys, as people are talking,
if you hear something that
really resonates with you,
please leave it down
in the comments below,
put quotes around it as
well, so other people
can be inspired, and when
you write something down,
it's much more likely to
stick with yourself as well.
Enjoy.
- Go hard, and then when
you think you're going hard,
go harder, like that's
really it, just hustle.
You know what I mean?
There's nothing in life that
you can't put enough work in
every single day and not get better at,
you know what I mean?
If you want to be good at
something, you know what I mean?
Like you can't just like
not like do it every day
and not get better.
It's the same shit with music.
It's the same shit with learning
how to play an instrument or something.
If you spend your time
practicing your craft,
like, you know, that's
really it, it's just,
you know, because now days
it's like with the Internet,
everything is so accessible and, you know,
everybody in the world is a
rapper, you know what I mean?
Everybody's putting music out,
so it's like how do you stand out?
Quality is always going to matter,
but also being different.
You can't try to be different,
you know what I mean?
But you just got to be yourself.
- [Interviewer] What's the
biggest risk you've taken
that you feel has paid off?
- The biggest risk I've
taken that has paid off.
I'd have to say Cookie.
I mean, I was very nervous
when I received the script.
She wasn't the most likable character,
and I've played some
pretty edgy characters,
but this one was particularly a challenge
because it was prime
time network television,
and I wasn't sure how
people would receive her.
I mean, she beat her son with a broom,
even though he deserved it.
She called one son a fagot.
I mean, it was scary, but
I'm the type of artist
that if the role doesn't
scare me, I don't want it,
because it's not going
to change me as a person.
So I took a risk, and that's
what you do as artists.
You jump in feet first
and you see where it goes.
And I knew that we had something special.
I don't just jump feet
first for any project.
I knew this was something special.
I knew that what Fox was trying to do,
what Lee Daniels and Danny
Strong were trying to do,
and what I was trying to do,
was shake up television.
It's too safe.
Life is not safe.
I think we did that with this show.
So I'm so proud to be
a part of this project,
and I'm so proud that Fox believed in us
and took a chance,
because that's what
art is about, isn't it?
Taking chances, taking risks (laughs).
- I think if you don't actually
believe what you're doing,
it's really important if you
don't derive satisfaction
from what you're doing,
then you will not be able
to sustain all of the
bad things that happen
in the incredibly long period of time
that the bad things happen over.
And so, the only motivation
that I have seen work for people
over a long period of time is enjoyment
in what they're doing
and an intense believe
that it matters, and
ideally liking the people
that they go to work with every day.
But the, I think the reasons
that a lot of people,
and by the way, it's
totally cool when people
start off saying well I want to make money
or I want to be famous.
I think a lot of people start that way,
and they don't like to admit it,
but pretty quickly, or at
least in the first few years,
I think a lot of people
find a deeper mission
for why they do what they do,
and that that drives them then
for the rest of the time they work.
- I look around at my
girlfriends and my guy friends,
and they're in jobs that
they don't really have a lot
of growth potential in, that
they're not passionate about,
and I think if we're ever
going to make bold decisions,
it has to be at this point in our life.
You know, we have to be out there,
we have to be experimenting,
we have to be looking
for that which makes us tick,
and I think a big part of that
evolution for me was really
summer jobs and working
and making sure to
actually get into the world
and try different things
and eliminate those,
which is as useful,
eliminating those career paths
that you're not interested in as it is
doing things that do interest you.
But I think just being
bold and taking risks
when you're young is so important
because I can't imagine
working the hours that I do
if I didn't fundamentally love it.
And I think that's the difference
between somebody whose successful
and somebody that's extremely successful.
Somebody that's good and somebody
that's exceptionally good.
Is the level of drive, which
directly stems from passion.
- There's different types
of people in this world,
and one thing that we're
all going to deal with
is like difficulties in our tasks
trying to become successful.
As good as things get,
you're going to have
the same amount of bad
that's going to try to impede
your progress, whether it be people,
whether it be the IRS,
whether it be whatever.
Something will rear its ugly
head and try to block you.
Now, a lot of people
can't handle that shit.
When you have a vision
and something or someone
throws a curve ball, it hurts.
It stings, right?
It's like your baby and
now I can't put my baby
out there like I want to do it,
so it really throws people off.
They get really negative.
They may get depressed.
They might want to stop.
They might just want to
back to their nine to five.
That's fine.
It's not for everybody to push through.
But for those who can push through,
like you said, the
difference between those
who really succeed and those who don't
are the ones who, when
they're faced with whatever
these difficulties are,
they're like I'm going
to keep pushing through.
I'm going to keep pushing through.
Because, it sounds corny and cliche,
but there's always
sunshine after the rain.
You know what I'm saying?
Rain don't last that long.
You got to know that and be aware of that.
That's something you can take with you
through everything in
life, but in business,
you cannot stop because
things are not going right
at the time, because it's going to happen.
I've dealt with it.
I'm sure I'll deal with
it again at some point.
- The number one thing that's
going to change your life.
The only thing that will change your life,
change your business, change your money,
change your relationship, is
you must raise your standard.
I know that sounds boring, stupid, basic,
but it's the truth.
The only thing that
changes our life long term
is when we raise our standards.
What does that mean?
That sounds so boring and dumb.
It means that all of us in
life have things we want.
We don't get what we want;
we get what we have to have.
Remember I said earlier, we
all get what we tolerate.
In ourselves, in other people.
But when you're no longer
willing to tolerate something,
that's when your life changes.
The difference in people
is their standards, period.
And what do I mean by standards?
Every one in the world
has a list of things
they think they should do.
I should lose weight.
I should work out.
I should spend more time with my kids.
I should work harder.
I should make more calls.
I should, I should, I should, I should.
And then you know what?
People don't do their shoulds,
and they get mad at themselves,
and they, what I call,
should all over themselves.
They beat themselves up about it.
What changes people is when
your should becomes a must.
When suddenly the thing
you said should happen,
has to happen.
That's when human beings change.
It's like if you want to take the island,
and you're the head of the army
and you want to take the island,
the most powerful way to take
the island is burn the boats.
Because if there's no way to go back,
it's amazing what happens when it's a must
to do something versus a should.
That's what makes human beings succeed.
- If you want to be a
fireman, go and do it.
If you want to be a ballet dancer,
then go and be a ballet dancer.
If you don't believe in yourself,
then no one else will believe in you.
It's an important, it's
so important for me
to people to understand that
I want to be an inspiration.
I was unique, as kind of
nine out of 10 children are,
and I wanted to be a role
model, and I think now
I'm in the kind of
limelight to go it's okay
and it's the special people that believe,
that ones that have something magical,
and it's something that you
can turn into a positive
and not let it eat you away.
There'll always be someone
that says you can't do it.
There'll always be someone that
says I don't believe in you.
There'll always be someone
that says I do believe in you,
and there's always someone
that says you can do it.
And that's the people
that you have to focus on.
However much people try to
put me down, which they do
when they say, you know,
every time I hear your song
I want to burn my ears,
I say whose laughing now.
- What it finally comes
down to in your business
and how you run it is
you first and me second.
Take that home with you.
You first and me second.
The first thing you want to do
is help your people succeed,
and then you succeed.
Just keep it in the right order.
It's not you succeeding and then hopefully
they come out okay.
It's all about them, not about you.
And I think that was the
foundation of our business.
We never, Jay and I never
talked about how much money
we made or how much
money we wanted to make.
We talked about how big we'd
like to have our business,
but it was never a
personal financial goal.
But our focus was on how
we could enrich the lives
of our people and make them better.
Often times influencing
them with our faith as well.
- I feel a genuine need to
communicate with an audience,
and it might just be the
attention I didn't get as a kid.
It can't come from anything good.
But what I try and do is
bring the best information
I can to the stage and broadcast it.
So it's reportage from distant points,
from a fairly unique
standpoint, and so basically
I'm not keeping it all to myself,
but I earnestly try to, it's
not about entertainment,
it's about communication,
warning, broadcasting,
emitting, and trying to
leave something of myself
with the audience.
It's not mere entertainment.
It's not just making people laugh or not.
It's got to hurt me.
It's got to leave lines in my face.
I don't like any artistic
endeavor that doesn't extol
a price on the one doing it.
So I'm not looking to get
through these things okay.
These things are actually very difficult
and very hard on my psyche,
which makes me think
I'm doing the right thing.
- Hublot came out with a product in 1980.
A product that was based on an innovation
to introduce rubber as a strap.
It seems very common
today, but rubber in 1980
was a real courageous move.
It was even the provocation.
People say hey, on a gold watch, rubber?
Because people didn't know
rubber comes from a tree,
rubber is natural, rubber
is very comfortable,
it's very flexible, and
rubber is very resistant,
and it's waterproof, so
finally it's ideal for a watch,
but in those days, people
thought it's a provocation,
and then Hublot could not evolve.
They stayed on the product, and
I said we are not a product.
We have a message first.
We have a concept.
And the concept is fusion.
Why?
Because in 1980, when we put
gold together with rubber,
we created a fusion
because gold and rubber
never come together.
They were together only one time in life,
during The Big Bang.
Then everything was in one.
Then rubber went away and
said okay I go now on my tree,
and gold said okay I go
and rest in South Africa
under the earth, and
since then they never met,
until people take them and connect them.
So I said Hublot made a fusion.
And fusion must be our message.
Must be our philosophy.
Must be our religion.
And once we have this religion clear,
and it is named fusion,
then we can develop further products.
Not necessarily need the rubber anymore
because fusion goes further
way than just rubber.
It can be carbon.
It can be ceramic, whatever.
So I was capable to free
Hublot from the product
and give Hublot a message,
and from that message,
new products were born.
And that was the most important element
in the revival of the brand.
It's to take it away
from a product concept
and to give it a brand message,
and from the brand message
were then later born in 2005 new products.
- When you finish a film,
your job basically is over.
You have a desire to share your work,
and so you put it out into the world.
You realize that yes you
can help the film some
by giving interviews or
you can go to some places
and have talks, but basically,
the film is on its own,
and you can't tell whether
it's going to go good
or going to go bad.
It's important that you
believe in your work,
and that's the most important thing.
- I watched so many matches
in my life, unbelievable.
And I really, there are some boring games,
and then I sleep, and
it's so boring and I think
why they meet each other
and make this 20, 40, 50,
60, 70, 80,000 people in a
stadium for this boring game.
It's not okay.
So that's what we want to see.
We want to enjoy our own game.
If we lose, okay, we like to win,
but if we lose, with our way it's okay.
If we lose with the way of somebody else,
it's, you cannot work
with this, so that's it.
It's very emotional,
very fast, very strong,
not boring, no chess, like this.
Yes of course tactical yes
but tactical with big heart
and tactical things are so important.
You cannot win without tactical things,
but the emotion makes the difference.
Life in our game, that's important.
- I remember I gave this talk
to a group of entrepreneurs,
and this one woman raised
her hand, and she goes
well, you're real positive,
but what do you do,
what do you tell yourself
when you just wasted
a year-and-a-half of
your life doing something
and it didn't work out.
And I told her, that's a real
negative way of looking at it.
Can you rephrase the question
and then ask me again.
Because you're looking
at it really negatively,
first of all, so I didn't even
want to answer it that way.
So she thought about it, and she said,
well I learned an important
lesson the hard way.
I said, that still sucks.
No wonder you don't want to move forward,
because you feel like
you've done something wrong
because it didn't work out
the way you had predetermined
you wanted it to work out.
You have to look at it a different way.
If you feel like you want to do something,
you should just step forward.
It may not work, but
you're going to hit a step
in your career and in your development
that you could not have taken
had you not gone that way
before you can get over there.
And I say in the ashes
of all your failures,
if you look close enough,
you'll find keys to success.
If you're a very negative person,
all you would focus on is
wow I have a really bad movie
on my resume that I wish I had never done.
But if you're a positive
person, you'll go I'm so glad
I took that step that most
people would not have taken
because that got me to a place
that no one else can follow.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I'd love to know what did you think,
what was your favorite clip,
what are you going to take
from this video and
immediately apply to your life
or your business somehow.
Leave it down in the comments below.
I'm super curious to find out.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Riza Pereira.
Thank you so much Riza for
picking up a copy of my book,
"Your One Word".
It really, really really
means a lot to me,
and I hope you enjoyed the read.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, I'll see you soon.